Today we're going to talk about
imperfect competition.
I want to start with just
a small
review of what we've done and then we'll
move to imperfect competition. I think
this fits in with a broader theme of the
course where or a broader approach in
the course where we're going to start
with some simple examples to try to
motivate the theory. Then we'll dig deep
into the theory and maybe prove some
theorems and then we'll apply the theory
to some substantive economic
applications. Today is going to be one
of those days where we dig into a
substantive economic application. So if
you don't have much of an econ
background, some of the of what we
covered today
may be new to you. If you have taken a
lot of econ courses, this may be a bit
of a review.
But just a reminder of of what we've
done so far, we've been studying
strategic form games and we've looked at
various solution concepts.
And we've said that in a strategic form
game, we apply this procedure of
iterated elimination of strictly
dominated strategies
and we
generated these nested sets
of strategies and at the end we got to S
infinity. And remember what we said is
that stronger assumptions about
rationality and higher order knowledge
of rationality allowed us to get sharper
predictions about how players will play.
And at the end when we get to S
infinity,
what we further know is that
uh
a subset of the rationalizable
strategies are maybe I'll jump down to
what we showed last time. We showed
these two relationships. So we showed
that every dominant strategy equilibrium
is a Nash equilibrium, specifically a
pure strategy Nash equilibrium.
And we showed that every pure strategy
Nash equilibrium
is rationalizable.
But there's actually one more inequality
or inclusion we can put here and here
I'll put mixed strategy Nash equilibrium
with positive probability.
So let me define
what I did here and and the proof of
this inclusion is quite similar to the
proof that we did in class last
Thursday. So I'd encourage you to to go
through the argument and see if you can
extend it to this case. So here what I
mean is this is the set of all strategy
profiles
that are played with positive
probability in some mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium.
So just to make sure we're on the same
page, why is it the case that every pure
strategy Nash equilibrium is an element
of this set? Why is every pure strategy
Nash equilibrium in this set of positive
probability mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium profiles?
Yeah.
That's fine. Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. Every pure strategy is a
mixed strategy, so that's the first
step. And then the second step is to
say, well, if something is a pure
strategy Nash equilibrium
it's also a mixed strategy Nash
equilibrium where everyone just plays
their component of that strategy profile
with probability one.
So since that's also a mixed strategy
Nash equilibrium, is this strategy
profile played with positive probability
in some mixed strategy Nash equilibrium?
Yes, in fact it's played with
probability one in a particular mixed
strategy Nash equilibrium. So it's clear
that this is a subset of this. The
argument that this is a subset of this
is maybe a little more involved, but as
I said, it's quite similar to the proof
we did last week.
Okay, so that's kind of the theory up to
the point that we've done so far. And
let me now move to the main application
for today which is imperfect
competition.
And to understand imperfect competition,
I think it's helpful to think of it as
falling between two extreme cases. So on
the one hand we have perfect competition
and then at the other extreme we have
monopoly.
And then imperfect competition falls
somewhere in between. So I'll put it
here.
Now formally defining these concepts can
be
a little tricky, but let me give some
ideas about what we mean and and again
people use these terms in slightly
different meanings in slightly different
ways in different contexts.
But perfect competition we normally
think of that as a setting where there's
many small firms.
Monopoly is a situation where we just
have one firm. They're the only firm
offering a particular good or product.
So here we have one firm.
Usually that one firm would be large
since they're the only firm.
And then imperfect competition lies
somewhere in between. We normally think
that there are maybe a few large firms.
This is sometimes also called oligopoly.
So a few
maybe large firms.
And the implication of this is that in
perfect competition when we have many
small firms each firm is what's called a
price taker.
What do I mean by that? I'm some small
firm in a market. I can't influence what
the market price is for the product that
I'm selling.
So the classic example of this would be
maybe commodities markets like wheat or
corn.
So if I'm a small farmer
and I'm choosing how much corn to
produce or to sell in the market this
year my decision about how much my
particular farm produces is unlikely to
affect the global market price for corn
because there's many many firms and many
many farms in the world that are
producing corn. And another important
aspect of this is that these are
homogeneous products and that's another
common attribute of perfect competition.
If we're all producing corn, but my corn
is special and better than everyone
else's corn, now I might not be such a
small player anymore.
Then in the case of imperfect
competition where we have a few large
firms, we normally think of what we say
is that these firms have market power.
What does market power mean?
It's really the opposite of being a
price taker. Though we can think of this
kind of as a continuum. With a price
taker, I have no control over the market
price for some item.
If I have market power, then my
production decisions can have some
effect on what the market price will be.
So when we have a few large firms, if
someone floods the market with a lot of
their goods, then the market price of
that good may fall. That's an example of
market power. So if there's a few
countries that produce oil in the world
and one of them, say Saudi Arabia,
produces much much more oil this year,
then that's probably going to have some
effect on the market price for oil. It's
probably going to bring down the market
price for oil.
Um when we have a few large firms, maybe
an example of this
there's different degrees of imperfect
competition, but maybe um you know, I
think cell phone
companies are good example in the US
where maybe you have two or three large
cell phone carriers that have their
large networks.
Um but we don't have a lot of small
firms and there's some barriers to
entry.
Um another example of market power could
be due to location.
So it may be that
there may only be a small number of
firms producing a good in a particular
area.
And this is going to be really relevant
when transportation costs are high.
So for instance,
um you know, maybe there's a lot of
coffee shops in the world, but right
around MIT there may only be a few and
if you take your coffee over long
distances, it's going to get cold, so
you're not really considering a coffee
shop in New York even if New York maybe
has better coffee than some places in
Boston.
Another source of market power could be
product differentiation.
And this is sort of what I was getting
at with the corn example. Corn is sort
of the opposite case where we don't see
much differentiation. But let's think
about Apple. You know, there's a lot of
different companies that produce phones
but you might find Apple iPhones to be a
different product than a Samsung phone
or a Google phone or a phone produced by
another firm. So even if there are many
companies that are producing a
smartphone
if these companies produce slightly
differentiated products, then Apple has
a bit of flexibility in what price it
charges. If an iPhone is a bit more
expensive than a Samsung phone, a lot of
people will still choose that phone
because they like Apple more and and the
same with Samsung. There may be some
Samsung loyalists out
And then monopoly is the case, sort of
the extreme case where we have a single
firm.
So they still have market power, maybe
they have extreme market power. It's
always hard to find example of a pure
monopoly, but can you think of any? Are
there any cases that you've come across
where you think there's really only one
firm that's selling a particular good or
offering a certain service or product?
Yeah.
The subway's a great example. Yeah.
Um
So the subway
say the MBTA in Boston
there's only one game in town.
You can't just as a private company say,
"I'm going to start digging up the
streets and building my own subway
system."
Now, of course,
what counts to monopoly it always
depends on what we consider a close
substitute. So, it is true that instead
of taking the subway, you could take a
blue bike or you could take a Lyft.
That's some kind of a substitute, but in
terms of getting on a train that goes
quickly underground and doesn't, you
know, have any contact with traffic,
that really is something that only the
MBTA, only a government monopoly is uh
is able to provide. What are some other
examples? Yeah. This is like more of a
monopsony, but like if you're in a coal
mining town and there's like only one
mining company. Right. Uh that's a great
example. So,
um
yeah, maybe monopsony, maybe I won't put
it up here just to avoid confusion with
monopsony, but that's a case where
you're the only buyer in town, right?
You're the consumer of labor, right? Uh
maybe the
you know, in that context, if there's a
labor market in that town, if there's a
labor union, that might be a monopoly in
that town as well, but that's a great
example of a monopsony. Uh yeah, in the
back. Normally like private companies
are contracted for like power or
something by the government.
Yeah, so often utilities and I and I put
cellphones up here, you know, they're
they're kind of it's a close call, but
some utilities
uh especially in a local market, you
know, if you have an apartment here in
Boston and you try to find your internet
provider, your phone provider, I guess
uh people don't have landline phones
anymore, but your internet provider, you
may only have one effective option,
right? Uh so, that's another good
example, yeah? I'm not sure if this is
imperfect competition or monopoly, but
like pharmaceutical companies and drugs
to me. Great. So, I I think uh again,
there's sometimes blurring lines between
imperfect competition and monopoly, but
I think a great example of this would be
a patent, right? So, if I'm a private
company and I produce a drug, I spend a
lot of money developing this drug, I'm
then given a certain period of time by
the government where I'm the exclusive
supplier of that drug. Now, again,
whether I'm a monopolist or not might
depend on well, is there a very close
substitute for that drug that's offered
by another company? But if I really come
along with a completely new drug, uh I
have a government uh monopoly. The
government says no one else is allowed
to produce the drug that you're
producing for some period of time. And
the goal of that is to give firms the
incentive to invest in these drugs cuz
developing them is quite expensive. Any
uh
final examples? These are all good.
I think another big one is sports. So,
the NFL, the MLB, there was actually a
Supreme Court ruling that gave the MLB,
you know, an official exemption from
anti-monopoly laws.
So, you know,
the NFL, we sort of take it for granted
there's a draft for the NFL,
why is there not a draft when you guys
are trying to get jobs at tech companies
after you graduate?
Well, they would not participate in a
draft, right? They're competing against
each other. So, the reason why we can
have a draft is that it's legal for
these firms to band together and enter
this, you know, collective agreement
where they all engage in a draft and
they uh agree to follow the rules of
this draft. If Google and Facebook tried
to have a draft for MIT students after
you graduated and have first round picks
and second round picks, that would
violate antitrust laws, right? But but
the NFL and the MLB and etc. uh have
gotten a special government exemption
and that allows them to do various
things, um
bargain with broadcasters in a
collective way, have things like a
draft, have restrictions on the building
of new stadiums and the development of
new teams.
Okay, so this is a bit of
actual economics, maybe more applied
economics for us today, but now let's
move into some of the classical
theoretical models that can explain
this. Maybe one more, I guess I had in
my notes that I didn't say would be um
the US Postal Service. Again, it's a bit
of a partial monopoly, there's very
specific services that no one else can
provide, but it does compete with say
UPS and FedEx for certain other
services. So, some of these things are a
bit uh are not so clear-cut. And of
course, when when firms go to court,
this is exactly what they argue about.
So, firms love to argue that there are
actually a lot of close substitutes for
their products and they're not really a
monopolist in this small market because
really they're operating in this much
broader market. So, firms always want to
argue that the market they're in is not
some narrowly defined market where
they're the only player, but in fact a
much broader broader market where
there's other forms of competition. So,
if I were the subway and I wanted to say
I'm not a monopolist, I would say, "No,
I'm in the transportation market." And
there's tons of forms of transportation.
Whereas if I wanted to argue they were a
monopolist, I might say, I might define
transportation a lot more narrowly.
Okay.
Um so, now that we have that background,
let's get into a few classical game
theoretic models that try to understand
the interaction of firms in imperfect
competition and in monopoly. And the
first ingredient for these models is
going to be defining what demand is.
So, again, if you've taken an econ
class, you will see this, but demand
captures at a given price, how many
units of a product am I willing to
purchase? Right? And naturally, your
demand for a product is going to depend
on the price. Generally, people will buy
more of something if the price of that
good is lower. Um but let's go through a
really simple example to try to make
this more concrete.
Let's think about, let's say it can be
the demand for apples, it doesn't really
matter. And let's say in this economy,
there's only three consumers. We'll call
them consumer one, consumer two, and
consumer three.
And apples uh
I would say are not an infinitely
divisible good. I mean, you could sell
half an apple, but that's really not
done. We're going to think of these as,
you know, you're only going to be able
to buy one, two, or three apples. You
can't buy 1.75 or you can't buy a
lottery over apples, though maybe you
you could at some point. Um so, let's
look at consumer one and let's say that
their valuation for the first apple they
get is $1. That's how much it's worth to
them to get an apple.
But they only want one apple. Once they
get that first apple, the value they get
from a second apple, the marginal value
of an additional apple drops to zero
because they're just not that hungry and
apples are perishables, they're not
going to it's going to go bad by, you
know, next week when they want another
apple.
Uh then we have consumer two. They're
similar to consumer one in that they
only value one apple, but they value
that first apple a bit more. So, for
consumer two, let's say that first apple
is worth $2 to them.
Uh but again, they only need one apple,
so after that
their value drops to zero.
And then consumer three really loves
apples and for them, the first apple is
worth three and they actually like would
even be willing to get a second apple.
Once they have the first, the second one
isn't quite as valuable, but it does
have positive value. So, that's going to
be $1 for the second apple and then zero
after that. And after that, it's going
to keep being zero.
They don't all of a sudden want the the
10th apple.
Um
so, once we understand the individual
consumers demand,
we can put it together to create a
market demand. But let's just make sure
we understand the individuals demand.
So, let's say I'm consumer three
and the price of apples is $4.
How many apples will I demand?
None, right? Because even this first
apple is not worth it to me. So, if the
price is $4, I'm not going to purchase
any apples.
But if the price is $2, then I'm going
to buy exactly one apple because the
first apple is worth three to me, so
it's worth it for me to buy that first
apple at $2.
But now once I've already bought one
apple, the additional value I get from a
second apple is only a dollar,
but I'd have to pay $2 to get it and
therefore it's not worth it for me.
So, using each of these individuals, we
can compute each of these individuals
demand. So, this is going to yield an
individual demand.
But if I'm a firm
and I'm considering what price to charge
for my apples, I don't really care about
individual demand.
I don't care if James is buying my
apple, I care about how many people in
the whole market are going to buy my
apples. So, what's relevant to the firm
is not the individual demand, but what's
called the market demand. And that's
what we're going to try to capture here.
So, what is the market demand for apples
in this very simple market that only has
three consumers?
Well,
what we're going to do is we're going to
need to plot the demand for apples as a
function of the price.
And there's a long convention in
economics that we always put price on
the vertical axis. So, if you think of
quantity as a function of price,
that may feel kind of backwards to you
from uh the way it's done in math, but
uh
this is just a historical convention.
Some people argue that there's good
reason for it, but we'll just take it as
a convention and we're always going to
write things this way. So, we have price
and quantity.
And on the horiz- on the vertical axis,
let me make some marks.
My drawing won't be perfect, but let's
say this is $1, $2, $3, $4, $5.
So, what we want to do is for each
price, we want to compute what is the
total quantity demanded at that price by
the market.
So, if the price is five,
what is the total market demand for
apples?
Zero, right? No one's willing to buy at
five. And in fact, no one's willing to
buy at four, either.
So, if we start up here, demand is just
zero. I'll try to make it shaded so you
can see it. It's 0 0 0, but then
something happens at three.
When the price drops down to three,
well, now
this person, player three, is willing to
buy exactly one apple, right? So, the
market demand is going to jump to one
when the price hits three. And I should
put uh some marks here.
So, here,
maybe I'll put it at a line like this,
it's going to jump up to one apple when
the price hits three.
And then it's going to stay if the price
is say 250,
well, that's going to make the third
consumer pretty happy if the price is
now only 250. He's actually going to
make a surplus uh from this first
purchase, but it's not going to entice
him to buy another apple.
And it's also not going to entice either
of these players to buy an apple. So,
the demand is going to be constant until
we hit a price of two and then at a
price of two, how many apples will be
demanded?
Now, two, right? Because the third
player is still going to demand an
apple, but now the second player is
going to demand one apple as well.
So now we're going to have this step
again up to two.
Okay, I think you can see the pattern,
but let's try to understand what happens
when you get to a price of one.
Now what is demand going to be when
price the price gets to be one or maybe
a little bit below one?
Now it's four.
And notice what happens. When the price
hits one, the first player is now
willing to buy one apple.
But that's not the only thing that
happens. Now the third player is willing
to buy a second apple instead of only
one apple. So now demand increases for
two reasons. We have new consumers
entering the market choosing to buy who
didn't previously buy, and we also have
this apple lover increasing the number
of apples that he buys from one apple to
two apples. So now it's going to jump up
to four
and then
it's going to stay like this. So we have
some
some jumps in the demand curve.
And it looks like this.
So that's our demand curve.
It looks kind of jagged.
And the reason is that we're only
considering a market with three people.
But if I'm a supermarket selling apples,
I'm hopefully selling to more than just
three people. So in reality, we're going
to be aggregating a lot of these
individuals. And the more individuals we
aggregate, as we change the scale of our
graph, it's going to get smoother and
smoother. So what we in our sort of
idealized model
with maybe many consumers
we're going to visualize this as a
continuous function.
Now you might argue, well, it's still
really discrete. Prices are discrete,
people are discrete, but
to make the math a bit cleaner, I think
not much is lost, and a lot is actually
gained in terms of tractability if we
make it continuous. So we might think of
a demand function that looks something
like this.
Just as an example.
So again, the interpretation is the
same.
As the price goes down, the total number
of apples demanded increases, and again
it increases for different reasons. It
can increase because some consumers
start buying who didn't previously buy,
and other consumers increase the number
that they actually buy.
So we're going to call this the demand
function, and we think of this as a
function Q of P.
So I always sort of have to turn my head
when I think about this. We have price
on the vertical axis, we have demand,
the total quantity demanded, on the
horizontal axis, and Q is a function of
P.
Now it's also sometimes helpful to think
of it the other way, to think
if I wanted a certain number of apples
to be demanded, what is the price that
would I I would have to set in order to
ensure that that was the demand? So
instead of thinking of the function from
prices to quantities, we could think of
it the other way
from quantities to prices.
And
we sometimes call this P of Q.
And this is often called the inverse
demand function. Because mathematically,
this is just the inverse, if we think of
Q of P as just a function, then P of Q
is literally the inverse of that
function.
So on problem sets and when we set
things up, sometimes we'll describe
demand
in terms of the demand function, the
demand as a function of price, and
sometimes we'll write down the inverse
demand, which is the price as a function
of quantity. These are just different
mathematical representations of exactly
the same object, which is a
correspondence between prices and
quantities.
Any questions on this?
Okay.
So now that we've set up demand, we'll
start with the monopoly problem. The
monopoly problem is a bit easier, we
don't really have to do game theory, and
you've probably seen this in other econ
courses, and then we'll move to
competition where we really have to take
into account um interaction between the
firms.
So now let's look at the monopoly
problem.
So what we imagine is I'm a monopolist,
I'm the only person selling some good,
say it's apples, but usually that's not
a good example of monopoly. Um and what
we're going to assume is that the
monopolist has some
constant
marginal cost
C, which is greater than or equal to
zero.
What do I mean by constant marginal
cost? What I mean is
if the monopolist wants to produce Q
units of a good
then the cost of those Q units is just C
times Q.
So here Q is just a number, C is just a
number.
We might think that, you know, at some
point it becomes really costly to
produce an additional unit. So often we
think that costs in general, you know,
at some scales become convex eventually,
that if you have to really, you know,
increase production and start hiring
people to work overtime and plant the
apples too close to each other in the
farmland, all these things, costs become
convex. Uh that's probably realistic in
a lot of settings, but let's stick to
constant marginal cost for now over a
certain range of production. That's
probably pretty realistic.
And now we have to specify the demand.
So let's understand here the difference
that these are assumptions about the
firm.
Which in this case is a monopolist.
And now when we write down things about
demand, we're not making assumptions
about the firm anymore, we're making
assumptions about the population of
consumers who are buying that firm's
product.
So what we're going to assume, just to
make the math pretty easy
is we'll assume that our demand
is Q of P
equals, well,
we want to just say 1 minus P.
So that as the price goes up
the demand goes down. That makes sense.
People buy less when the price is
higher.
But the problem is, well, if the price
gets really high, then this demand would
be negative.
And that's kind of a a problem. We don't
think that demand is ever negative. So
we're going to write the maximum
of 1 minus P and 0.
So that once the price gets high enough
specifically when the price gets above
one, demand is just going to be zero. No
one's willing to buy at that price, but
demand won't actually become negative.
Now
when we solve things
we often kind of cheat a little bit, and
we sort of forget about the max, and we
hope that at the end the prices we
consider won't be big enough that this
matters. So what we'll often do is we'll
kind of reason as if the max isn't here,
and hope that at the end our answer
involves a price that's less than one.
And if it does, that's not going to be a
problem, but if we found a price greater
than one, then we'd have some issues. So
that's just something to keep in mind
uh when you're working with these kinds
of demand functions.
And
let's remind us that this is
an assumption
well, not just about one consumer,
because we have many, many consumers, so
it's an assumption about the population
of consumers.
Sometimes you hear about demand side and
supply side economics. These are
assumptions about the supply side, the
supplier of the good, and these are
assumptions about the demand side, the
consumers who consume the good.
Okay, so now let's draw this, and I want
to be a little more precise. Not only is
C greater than or equal to zero, but
let's actually say it's between zero and
one.
It's going to make things a bit easier.
It could be exactly zero, but let's say
it's strictly positive, and it's between
zero and one.
So now let's draw
this demand.
So as usual, I'm going to have quantity
on the horizontal axis
and price on the vertical axis.
And let me mark
one and one.
Of course, you know, this just makes the
numbers easy, but if you want to think
of this depending on the product, maybe
this is 1 cent or $1 or $100 or $1,000,
but we'll just call it one. And
similarly, maybe this is tons of apples
or, you know, bushels of apples. It
could be various things, but we'll just
use these simple units here.
And what does this demand look like?
Well, if the price is greater than one,
then no one's willing to buy at all,
right? So
the demand
looks like that until we get to one.
If the price is exactly one
then demand is zero.
And on the other hand, if the price is
zero
then demand is one.
So we know that there's Here's another
point on the demand curve.
And because of the form of our demand,
this is what's called a linear demand.
So the demand curve is just going to be
a straight line that connects our point
here and our point here.
So
maybe I'll draw it something like this.
If my axes were straight, this should be
a uh
I guess
an isosceles triangle, but maybe I
haven't done it quite right.
Okay.
And just so we understand
at any price P here
this value
is Q of P. Let's understand. So at this
price here, I walk horizontally to the
value of the function Q of P, I come
down, and that's the value Q Q here.
Which is In this case is exactly 1 - P.
Okay. So, now I need to write represent
one more thing on the graph. So far the
graph is only representing the demand
side of the market. Now, I also want to
represent the firm's costs. So, let me
put C here
and I'll draw a horizontal line here.
So, this is going to represent the
firm's cost of production.
And now let's understand if the firm
were to set a price of P, what would
their profits be? So, let's try to write
this down.
I want to understand what is pi of P.
So, this is suppose I'm the monopolist,
I choose to set a price of P,
what are my profits going to be if I set
this price of P?
Well, let's break it down into two
parts.
The first is my profit per unit that I
sell.
So, for each unit that I sell, I sell it
at a price of P,
but I have to pay a cost of C to produce
it.
So, my profit per unit is
P minus C.
But then the question is I'm getting
this profit per unit, but how many units
do I actually sell? So, it's going to be
P minus C times Q of P.
And now we see the basic trade-off that
the monopolist faces.
What happens when the monopolist raises
their price?
They
increase their profit per unit,
right? If I increase the price of
apples, each apple I sell is great for
me. I'm making a lot of money on each
apple I sell.
But, when I raise that price, I'm not
going to sell as many apples. So, the
number of units that I sell goes down.
And the basic trade-off for the
monopolist is to balance these two
effects, the per unit profits against
the total number of units that are sold.
Uh
and
let's write this
for prices that are between 0 and 1,
this is going to take the form like
this, right? So, in general Q of P is
the maximum of 1 minus P and 0.
But as long as P is not too big, then
this is just going to reduce to 1 minus
P and I can substitute this in here.
Now, we can nicely see this graphically.
Graphically, if I look at this price P,
well,
this is going to be
the amount that I sell,
and P minus C is my profit per unit. So,
what I see is I can actually shade in
my profit as this square or rectangle.
So, the shaded rectangle
equals profit.
Let's make sure we understand it.
I could actually look at the entire
rectangle all the way down to the
horizontal axis. That would represent
revenue
because that entire rectangle, it's
area is its height, which is the price,
times its its width, which is the
demand.
So, the entire rectangle tells me the
price times the amount that I sell.
That's revenue. That's the amount of
money I take in,
but I'm not counting this little part of
the rectangle
in my profit because this is the cost I
have to pay to produce that amount. So,
remember profit
is profit, which equals revenue
minus cost.
Revenue meaning the total amount of
money that I take in,
and cost being the amount that I have to
pay in order to produce the amount that
I sell.
So,
I don't want to make the graph too ugly,
but this would be
the cost.
I have to pay a cost of C per unit,
and then the width here is the number of
units that I sell.
So, what is the monopolist trying to do?
They're trying to choose this price P
to maximize their profit. That is choose
this price P to make this rectangle to
make the area of this rectangle as large
as possible.
Now, let's just understand some extreme
cases, some things they wouldn't want to
do.
What if they set the price to be one?
What would their profit be?
Zero, right? If they set the price to
one, no one's going to buy.
What if they set the price to C?
Then their their profit is also zero. A
lot of people are going to buy, but if
they're charging exactly what their cost
is, they're not making any money. And in
fact, if they set a price below C,
they'd actually be losing money
because their revenue would be smaller
than their cost.
So, it's pretty clear that the price
should be somewhere between 1 and C, and
let's actually figure out what that is.
So, let's now find the optimal monopoly
price.
So, maybe I'll call it the monopoly
problem.
Well, what is the monopolist doing?
They're maximizing
over the price P
of pi of P,
which equals P minus C times 1 minus P.
Now again, you could say I'm not this is
not quite correct
because technically for some prices they
might choose, this is not a reflection
of demand, right? But,
this is the correct formula for the
reasonable range of prices between 0 and
1. And if I check at the end that the
price I get is between 0 and 1, then
everything's going to be okay. But but
recognize that I'm not literally
claiming that if my price is 10, then my
profit is going to be negative because
if I set a price of 10, in fact, my
profit will be zero because no one's
going to buy the good.
Well, how do we maximize a single
variable function? We take derivatives,
right? And set them to zero. You can
check that this is going to be a concave
function. So, if we set the derivative
to zero, we'll actually find the
maximizer.
And so, the derivative pi prime of P,
well, we're just going to use the
product rule.
So, we take the derivative of the first
term times the second.
The derivative of the first term is one.
So, we just multiply that by the second
term and we get 1 minus P.
Then we have the first term P minus C
times the derivative of the second term,
which is negative one.
So, we get negative one here.
So, we get 1 minus P plus
minus 1 times P minus C. Let's try to
simplify this.
Well, we're actually going to get 1
plus C
minus 2 P.
So, we want to set this to zero.
And solve for zero equals this.
We're going to pull the 2 P to the other
side and divide by P, and what we can
see is that the monopoly price P star is
going to be 1 plus C
over 2.
So, in fact, it will be the price. What
is 1 plus C over 2 geometrically? It's
the midpoint between 1 and C.
And if you draw this correctly, the
optimal price 1 plus C over 2 will
actually make this rectangle a square.
Um I won't try to show it here cuz I
think my my picture isn't exactly to
scale.
Uh but what you'll find is that
uh
this this will be a square.
And this is actually a nice geometric
fact. So, you could do all the calculus
here. I mean, it's not too hard in this
case, but it sometimes gets messier. One
way to think about this is well, P minus
C
plus 1 minus P,
uh
that turns out to be a constant. So,
what you're actually being asked to do
here is to find a rectangle of maximal
area given a fixed perimeter.
So, this is just a reflection of the
geometric fact that if I fix a perimeter
and I ask you to find a rectangle of
largest area given that perimeter, it's
going to be a square. So, that's
actually why we get a square here. Um
but I don't know. That's just a a fact
to keep in mind.
Okay. So, now we found P star. Let's now
find Q star.
So, Q of P star
is going to be what?
Well, Q of P is just 1 minus P. So,
we're going to get
minus
1 plus C over 2.
And if we simplify that, we can think of
this as 2 over 2.
So, we're going to get 1 minus C over 2.
So, what this says is
it's going to be optimal for the
monopolist to set a price of 1 plus C
over 2.
And when they set that price, the number
of units they're going to sell is 1
minus C over 2.
Now, the first thing we should observe,
which I think makes sense, is that
the price the monopolist finds it
optimal to charge is increasing in their
production costs.
And this makes sense. So, whenever you
solve these problems, I think it's good
to kind of go through the intuition.
Does it make sense that when something
is more expensive to produce, I charge a
higher price? Yeah, that certainly makes
sense.
And in fact, it's often helpful to
decompose this
in a in a very special way.
So, we can actually write this as
C plus
1 minus C over 2.
Let's check that that that agrees,
right? This is 1/2
plus 1/2 of C, right? And this is C
minus C over 2, so we still have a half
C,
and then we have a 1/2. So, so the
algebra works out.
And it's helpful to decompose it this
way because C is the cost of production,
so this term has a name.
Has anyone heard that what what we might
call
this term here?
This is often called the markup, right?
And you might talk about it. You go to a
store,
say, "Wow, that's a really high markup."
If you go to a restaurant, I could buy
this chicken at, you know, a grocery
store for this price, but this
restaurant is charging a lot more.
That's the markup, right? It's the
difference between the price you're
paying and the cost that they're
actually paying to produce it. So, this
is called the markup.
So, we see that monopolists charge a
markup. They don't charge a price equal
to their cost of production, they charge
a price that's strictly higher than
their cost of production, and that's
because they're taking advantage of or
exploiting their monopoly power.
Great.
So, now let's move to the actual game
theory and think about what happens if
we have
um
multiple
firms.
So, now what if there are multiple
firms?
Well, we have to think how are these
firms going to compete?
It's not so clear what they're doing,
and we're actually going to study two
classical models of how firms compete.
So, one model is that they
what is what's called quantity
competition.
And here, I think the model you should
have in mind is you're a farmer, you
think of two farmers, they're choosing
how many apples to bring to the market,
and once they get to the market, the
price that they can get at the market
depends on how many apples people bring
to the market. So, here, in quantity
competition,
firms choose quantities,
and then the market chooses the price.
Maybe sets price.
So, this is sort of the oil example I
gave earlier.
If the US, say, I gave Saudi Arabia
before, let's say the US, if the US
increases its oil or its natural gas
production and floods the market,
that's going to decrease the market
price of oil.
So, the US isn't just saying, "This is
the price of oil I'm charging." They
produce more oil, and then they sort of
have to take the price that they're
given.
Um so, that's the model of quantity
competition. The other model is maybe
the more traditional model that you
think of of price competition,
where here,
firms choose prices. You have two stores
side by side, they each post a sign that
says, "This is how much it costs to buy
this item at our store."
So, here,
firms choose prices,
and then those prices determine how much
consumers actually buy from each store.
So, then,
you could say the market sets demand, or
I'll say quantities,
maybe I'll say the market
chooses demand.
Or chooses quantity.
So, I see two stores, they each have a
sign that says how much they're
charging, and I choose which store to go
to.
So, I think these are two very natural
ways of
thinking about competition.
We're going to find in the next few
minutes that these actually give very
different answers.
So, I think
there's sort of the math which
allows us to analyze these two models,
and then I think the job of the
economist is to try to figure out which
of these models is more appropriate in a
particular situation.
Because they both seem reasonable, um
and I gave a few examples of markets
that might fit one better than the
other, but whenever we have two models
that both seem reasonable, they give
very different results, we really have
to think hard about which is the right
model to capture the situation we have
in mind.
So, it turns out this one came came
first. This is a model by Cournot.
Uh I like it's easy to remember these
dates cuz they sort of mirror each
other. This was in 1838.
Uh and then this model of price
competition is by Bertrand.
And this is actually 1883. I mean, the
dates don't matter, but I just think
it's
fun that they
the dates are like that. Uh and, you
know, Cournot came along, wrote down
this model. He was motivated um by
actually spring water, these two firms
that were sitting on a spring and were
I don't know, bottling, or I don't know
how water was sold in the 1800s, putting
water into buckets and selling it.
And then Bertrand wrote kind of an angry
article a few years later saying, "This
is kind of a crazy way to model
competition. Firms don't produce qua-
choose quantities, they choose prices."
And today, modern industrial
organization economists still think
about different ways of modeling
competition and what's the right way to
think about it. There's no right way,
but, you know, in different situations,
which one is better.
Okay, so now let's write down
what what the profits are.
So, we'll start with Cournot. We'll go
chronologically.
So, this is sometimes known as quantity
competition, sometimes called Cournot
competition. Those are synonymous. So,
maybe here I'll call it Cournot
competition.
So, what's the model? We have two firms,
and we'll call those firms one and two.
And each firm has the same constant
marginal cost of production.
So,
we'll say constant
marginal cost C
at both firms.
And let's assume C is between zero and
one, just as we did before.
And now we have market demand.
We're actually going to look at the
inverse demand, cuz it's a bit more
convenient in this setting.
P of Q
equals 1 minus Q.
But notice here that this inverse demand
is actually exactly the same demand we
had before.
Because if P of Q equals 1 minus Q,
well, how do I get Let's solve for Q.
That means Q is equal to 1 minus P. So,
this is exactly the inverse demand
that is associated with this demand over
here. So, these are just two different
ways of writing it.
Um
And again, with the understanding that
uh if quantity gets too big, then the
price is just zero. So, if I wanted to
be really formal, I would say the
maximum
of 1 minus Q and zero.
But this is a crucial point.
This Q here
is
the market quantity.
So, the price
at the market depends on how much water
is brought to market,
but the amount of water or apples
brought to market depends on the entire
market, not just an individual firm.
So, the crucial thing here is that each
firm I
chooses
a quantity QI. So, firm one chooses
their quantity Q1, and firm two chooses
their quantity Q2. And notice this is
lower case.
So, we're generally going to use lower
case to denote the quantity chosen by a
particular firm,
but the individual choices of the firms,
when added together, determine what
determine what the market demand is.
So, in this case, the market quantity Q
is going to be the sum of the amount
produced by each firm. So, this is going
to be
Q1
plus Q2.
And the final assumption, maybe I'll
write it explicitly, is that firms
maximize profits.
Expected profit. All right, I guess
there's no I'll say profit.
Now, remember, this is an import- an
important assumption. Going back to what
we said before, when we set up game
theory, we said what people maximize is
utility,
and utility is not always the same as
money.
So, another way of saying firms maximize
profit is that firms are risk neutral.
Right? Their their von
Neumann-Morgenstern utility function as
a function of money is just linear.
Is this a reasonable assumption? In some
contexts, yes, in other contexts, no.
So, maybe in other contexts, we'd really
want to think of a firm that's risk
averse over their profits, but in this
model, we're assuming they're risk
neutral, so all they're trying to do is
maximize profits.
Okay, so now let's write down
what the profits are.
So, let's look at firm one.
It's easier to reason from one firm's
perspective, though it's always going to
be symmetric.
I'm going to write pi one
of Q1 Q2.
So, let's just understand. Pi is often
used for profits, just cuz it's the
Greek pi, like P for profit,
and we already used P for prices, so we
use pi for profits.
What I want to understand is I'm firm
one, what is the profit that I get
if I produce a quantity of Q1 and the
other firm produces a quantity of Q2.
Well, let's understand this.
Well, just as before, we can decompose
this into two parts. We have to keep
track of
my profit per unit and then the number
of units I have.
Well, we already The number of units I
have is easy, so let's write that down.
That's Q1.
Q1 is the number of units I sell.
But then, what is going to be my profit
per unit?
Thoughts here?
So, what do I want to multiply Q1 by?
1 - Q1 + Q2.
Uh yes, there's a parenthesis in there.
Yeah, exactly. So, let me write it
um
Let me first write it as this
and then I'll break it down in the way
you suggested.
So, Q1 is the amount I'm producing.
What is my profit per unit? Well, my
profit is just the price that I'm able
to sell it for minus the cost of
production.
But the tricky thing here is what is the
price? Well, the price is determined by
the market demand
and therefore, it's P of the market
quantity. Sorry, not market demand,
market quantity, which is the sum of Q1
+ Q2, the market supply. And this is
what makes this a game theory problem.
Because
how well I do as firm one depends not
only on what I produce and what I bring
to market, but also on what my opponent
brings to market, Q2. Why does it matter
how much my opponent produces? Because
how much my opponent produces affects
the price at which I sell my goods.
So, now we have a strategic interaction
between the two firms.
And let's write this out once more. We
have Q1 times, well, P of Q1 + Q2 is
just 1 -
in parenthesis Q1 + Q2, so that's 1 - Q1
- Q2
- C.
So, now it doesn't really make sense to
say what is my optimal quantity.
With the monopolist, we just said, what
price should I charge? That was easy.
Now
the optimal quantity for me depends upon
the quantity that the other firm
produces.
So, instead of just talking about an
optimal quantity, we have to talk about
a best response. Now, we have a game,
right? Let's understand this as a game.
A strategy for firm one is a quantity.
A strategy for firm two is also a
quantity. And the utility of firm one is
given like this and we could
symmetrically write down the utility for
firm two. So, now we have a game and we
can talk about best responses. So, a
best response
by firm one
to a quantity Q2
is equal to what?
Well
we need to maximize this expression and
this kind of expression comes up a lot,
so I want to You can do the algebra, but
I think it's nice to know a little
trick. So if you're ever maximizing
something like this, where A is positive
So, I'm choosing X to maximize X times A
- X.
You can just derive this with calculus,
but what you'll find is X = A over 2.
That's always the optimum. And this this
kind of form comes up again and again,
so it's just a nice thing to know right
away for exams and quizzes.
Uh again, it's the fact that uh
a rectangle of constant perimeter, its
area is maximized by a square, right? If
I take X = A over 2 then both of these
terms are equal to A over 2. That's the
geometry of it. You can do calculus to
solve it, but now we can immediately
find what my best response is, right? We
just have to be careful to figure out
what the A is, right? So, we have to
think, okay, I'm firm one, I'm choosing
Q1.
So, from my perspective what part of
this do I control and what part of this
is a constant?
Yeah. Q1 is controlled, Q2 is a
constant. Right, so Q1 is controlled, so
the A here is 1 - Q2 - C.
Right, we can think of this as the
constant A - Q1 where A is 1 - Q2 - C.
So, if I just do this out, I see that my
best response is 1 -
Q2 - C
divided by 2.
Okay. And again, let's ask if this makes
sense. So, as before, we see that the
amount I produce is decreasing in the
cost.
So, if the cost of production is higher,
I produce less. Does this make sense?
Can someone give intuition for this? Why
do I want to produce less when the cost
of production is higher?
Why don't I just keep producing more?
Any thoughts?
Well
my amount of production affects the
market price. So, if the cost is really
high it's only worth it for me to
produce if the market price is high,
which means I can't keep producing a
lot, otherwise I'd pull the market price
down too low. So, again a higher cost
means I produce less simply because I
require a higher price to make it worth
it.
And then, it's also decreasing in Q2.
So, the more that my competitor
produces, the less that I produce.
Does that make sense?
Well, if my Yeah?
What?
They are producing more than the price
is right now. Exactly right. So, the
more they produce
the lower the price I'm going to face
for a given amount of my production and
therefore, it's optimal for me to
produce less.
Okay.
So, now we've computed the best
responses. I've only done it one way,
but we can see what it's going to be for
the other firm, right? BR2 of Q1 is just
going to be symmetric. It's going to be
1 - Q1 - C over 2.
So, if I'm firm two
and and firm one is choosing a quantity
of Q1, this is the optimal quantity for
firm two to produce.
Okay?
And now I want to solve for an
equilibrium.
Which means I need
Maybe I'll just write it like this.
Maybe I'll put these in here.
So, what is my equilibrium condition? In
equilibrium, each firm is playing a best
response to the other firm's quantity.
So, I need Q1 star, what firm one is
choosing, to be a best response to what
Q2
firm two is choosing
and I need the amount of produced by
firm two, Q2 star
to be a best response for firm two to
the amount produced by firm one.
So, I now have a system of equations.
But let's understand, my system of
equations, it's a linear system of
equations
and it has two equations and two
unknowns.
And in general, we can solve those
systems pretty easily. We could go
through the algebra, but I'll just I'll
spare you the algebra and what we'll get
is Q1 star
equals Q2 star
equals
1 - C over 3.
And let's ask, what is the market price
going to be in this case?
Well, the market price
is going to be 1
Q1 - Q2.
But each of these is 1 - C over 3.
But I subtract that twice, so I get 1 -
2/3
1 - C.
And again, it's nice to to pull C out.
So, we can do a little trick. This is C,
let's add C and subtract C and what we
get is C plus
1 - C over 3.
So, one thing we can make a comparison
with our monopoly case. In our monopoly
case, where we had only one firm
the markup was 1 - C over 2.
Here, when we have two firms competing
in Cournot, the markup is 1 - C over 3.
So, we see that we have a a smaller
markup, which uh which maybe makes
sense.
And we can actually generalize this. So,
let's
I want to understand it intuitively.
So, let's look at the general case
with N firms.
And this we can actually just guess by
the form that we have here. So, I'm not
going to go through the derivation, but
I'm just going to write down the answer.
And it's pretty easy to check using the
same argument.
So, we have N firms
how much is each firm going to produce?
Maybe I'll write Q1 star
equals QN star.
So, it turns out with N firms, we're
going to have a symmetric equilibrium.
Every firm is going to produce the same
amount.
And based on our pattern with two firms,
they each produce 1 - C over 3.
And notice in the monopoly case
we got Did we solve for Q?
1 - C over 2.
Now, in the monopoly case, they were
choosing prices, but actually with the
monopolist, whether you choose price or
quantity doesn't make a difference. So,
with one firm, we got 1 - C over 2. With
two firms, we got 1 - C over 3. It's a
pretty clear pattern there. It's always
1 - C divided by the number of firms
plus one, right?
So, this is 1 - c
over n + 1.
So, I think this makes sense. Let's
again go through our intuition.
Each firm produces less when the cost is
higher. That makes sense. Each firm also
produces less when the number of other
firms goes up. So, the more firms there
are, the less each firm produces.
And the reason is that the residual
demand that they can capture is lower.
The other The other firms are already
capturing a lot of the market, or
another way of saying it is the other
firms are already dragging down the
price.
So, I don't want to bring so much more.
It's also good though to look at the
total
market
quantity. So, Q star, which equals Q1
star
up to Qn star
is let's sum up the amount produced by
each firm. So, we can look at the total
amount produced by the market.
And what we're going to get is n over n
+ 1
* 1 over c.
So, what we see is that this is
decreasing in n.
But this is increasing in n.
So, when there's more firms, each firm
produces less,
but the total amount produced by all the
firms is actually increasing.
And as n gets really large, what is this
going to approach?
Just 1 - c, right? Because n over n + 1
is going to converge to 1.
So, we just get 1 - c. So, I'll say in
this converges to 1 - c
as n goes to infinity.
And what about the market price?
Remember, it doesn't make sense to talk
about the firm's price cuz they're all
selling at the same price. So, there's a
firm quantity and a market quantity, but
there's only a market price. There's no
individual firm price
in this model.
Again,
we can see the pattern. This is going to
be c + 1 - c over
And this is decreasing in n.
And again, I think this makes sense,
right? The more firms there are,
the stiffer the competition between the
firms,
and the lower the price is.
And in fact,
what happens to the markup as n gets
really big?
The markup goes to zero.
So, what we see is that the market price
in this case converges to c
as n goes to infinity.
And this exactly captures perfect
competition. So, when there are many,
many firms competing with each other,
they no longer have the market power to
charge a markup, and in the limit as we
have many, many firms, every single firm
uh well, every firm is going to produce
the quantity such that the market price
is exactly equal to cost of c.
And
can anyone interpret
1 - c?
Why do we get 1 - c as the quantity in
this case?
Turns out this is the what we might call
the efficient quantity.
What do I mean by efficient? Well, if it
costs c to produce a good,
who for whom is it efficient to buy the
good? It's efficient for people to buy
the good if they value it more than the
cost of production.
But our demand curve exactly tells us
that
the number of people who value the
product, or more precisely, the number
of units of the product that have
marginal utility above c is exactly 1 -
c. So, what happens when we have many,
many firms is we converge to an
efficient outcome. The market price is
exactly c,
and the amount that's produced and
consumed is exactly the amount that's
efficient to produce and consume.
Um people who value each unit at more
than c are going to buy it, and people
who don't value it at more than c don't
buy it. Um
So, we see this is sort of an initial
uh illustration that perfect competition
leads us to efficiency.
And here a perfect competition meaning
the limit as the number of identical
firms grows very, very large.
Good. Any questions about this?
Yeah. Compared to like some other
quantity other than 1 - c, like why is
why are those other quantities
inefficient? Great. So, let's look at
the Do we have a
demand curve
somewhere? I think it's
I forgot if I've erased something. I may
have erased it.
So, let me just draw a little curve
here.
So, one way to interpret
This comes down to how we interpret
demand
Q of P.
So,
what Q of P means, let's imagine just to
make the argument simpler that everyone
only consumes one unit of the good. So,
when demand's going up as price drops,
it's because more people are choosing to
buy, not because a single person is
buying multiple units. The argument goes
too, but let's that will just make it
simpler.
So, what Q of P is,
it's the number of people who are
willing to buy at price P. Right?
But let's think this through a little
bit differently. Who's willing to buy at
price P?
It's people whose value for the good is
at least P.
So, another way of thinking of demand Q
of P is exactly it's the number of
people
It's the number with value
at least P.
It's the number of people who say for
them the apple is worth at least P.
But that means that Q of C,
which in our example is exactly 1 - c,
it's the demand at c, is exactly the
number of people whose value is at least
cost.
So, this captures If we look at everyone
in the population, some people value the
good at more than it costs to produce.
Some people value it at less than it
costs to produce. The efficient
allocation is for people to get the good
exactly if their value for the good
exceeds the cost of producing.
And that's In this case, that turns out
to be 1 - c. It's the number of people
whose value for the good is more than 1
- c.
Good. Any other questions?
Good. Okay. So, now that we've done
Cournot, in the last few minutes, let's
move to Bertrand competition. So, maybe
come down.
No, I guess I'm going to get stuck with
these boards.
Let me I'll come all the way over here.
So, now let's look at Bertrand
competition.
So, almost everything's the same as
before. We still have two firms. They
still have constant marginal cost of c,
and demand still takes the same firm the
same form. So,
uh firms, I'll just write it quickly,
firms one and two
constant marginal cost c,
and the market demand
and this time it's more convenient to
write it this way, the demand Q of P
equals the max
of 1 - P and 0,
and c where c is between
0 and 1.
But now, the difference with Bertrand is
that we imagine that instead of firms
choosing quantities, they choose choose
prices.
So,
each firm i
chooses a price Pi.
And now we have to try to understand
what are consumers going to do.
If firm one charges a price of P1,
and firm two chooses a price of P2, what
would you do as a consumer?
Which firm would you buy from?
Firm with the lower price, right? So,
our assumption is going to be that
whenever the firms charge different
prices, all consumers buy from the lower
priced firm.
And how many units do they buy? Well,
they buy from the market demand at that
lower price.
So,
let's
see if we can write down
a formula.
So, mathematically, so we understand
this is a story, this is a motivating
story, but mathematically, this is just
a game, and we have to specify the
strategies and the payoffs. We've
already specified the strategies because
what each firm chooses is a price.
So, to finish specifying this
mathematically as a game, we need to say
what is each firm's payoff as a function
of the price she charges and the price
that the other firm charges?
So, let's do it it's symmetric. Let's do
it from the perspective of firm one.
What I want to understand is pi one of
P1 P2.
So, as before we're going to use pi to
denote profit. I'm going to write pi one
to say this is firm's one firm one's
profit. But now firm one's profit is not
a function of the quantities we choose
but it's a function of the prices that
we choose.
And
this is going to take a different form
depending on the relative values of P1
and P2. So, let me break this up into
cases. There's going to be the case
where P1 is less than P2.
There's going to be the one where case
where P1 equals P2 and the case where P1
is greater than P2.
All right. So, let's try to fill this
in. I think this is the easiest case
here. So, if I charge more than my
opponent, what is my profit going to be?
Just zero, right? I'm not going to sell
anything.
So, I get zero here.
Now, let's do this case. If I charge
less than my opponent,
well, now
let's first let's break it up into two
pieces as we always do. We need to think
about what is my profit per unit and
then what is the number of units I'm
going to sell.
So, my profit per unit is going to be P1
minus C, right? I'm selling at a price
of P1 and my cost is C.
And notice how this is kind of dual to
what we did before. Before I directly
chose quantity but the price depended on
what the other person did.
Here I directly choose price but the
quantity depends on what the other
person does and also what I do.
So,
what is going to go
in here? What is going to be the
quantity I sell
at price P1?
Well, everyone if they buy is going to
buy from me.
So, the amount that I sell is going to
be the market demand at a price of P1.
But we already said the market demand at
a price of P is just 1 minus P. So,
we're going to get 1 minus P1.
Again, assuming P1 is less than one but
we're going to be a little sloppy.
And now we see the same central
trade-off but kind of in the other way.
Uh if I raise my price, I get more per
unit but the number of units I sell goes
down.
What about this case? This is a little
tricky. We have to make an assumption.
What happens if both firms charge
exactly the same price, right? Uh yeah.
They both get half of the market. Right.
That's the standard assumption that if
consumers are indifferent, maybe they
randomize, maybe they you know, whatever
for whatever reason, it's going to be
half half. So, it's going to be
P1 minus C times 1 minus P1 over 2.
So, we're both charging the same price
P1. The market demand is 1 minus P1 but
I get half of that and my opponent gets
half of it.
So, now mathematically we we're done.
We've described the game.
Um
now what we want to understand is the
best response. So, now let me understand
the best response
of firm one
to a price of P2.
And it's going to be a few cases we have
to be careful about. So, let's break
this down. The first case is if P2 is
less than C.
Next case if P2 equals C.
Next case is if C is less than P2.
And there's going to be a final case at
the end which I'll get to. So, but let's
go through it step by step.
What if my opponent charges a price less
than C?
Strictly less than C.
What price would I like to charge? Yeah?
Well, at that point you should just
not because if you compete with them and
actually get customers, you're not going
to be making
Great. So, the only way I'm going to be
able to sell to anyone is if I charge a
price that's
at most P2.
But that price is already below C. So,
I'm definitely going to lose money. So,
the best I can do is get a payoff of
zero. But what price will ensure that I
get a payoff of zero?
Uh well, zero actually would not be a
very good price to set, right? Uh I need
to charge well, let's see. There's a lot
of things I could do.
Um
I
I can actually charge um
it's a little tricky but actually
anything above P2 is going to work. So,
maybe I'll write it down as a set. I
mean, we're being a little careful here.
Um
if my opponent charges P2, you're
exactly right that my goal is to sell
nothing
because the only way I can sell
something is if I'm losing money.
How do I ensure that I sell nothing?
Well, I don't even want to charge P2
because then I'll get half the market
and then I'll lose money on that half.
So, it has to be strictly above P2. Uh
so, anything strictly above P2 up to
infinity. So, I'm using uh round
parentheses to denote strict
inequalities.
Now, in particular, I mean, one thing
that's weird about this is I might be
willing to charge a price below cost
which seems really strange but I'm
willing to do it as long as the other
person's price is even lower and I'm not
actually going to sell.
What if my opponent charges exactly C?
Now, what do I
what am I willing to
to charge? Again, I'm not going to be
able to make any money because the best
I can do is sell it at a price of C and
my cost is C. So, I'm not going to make
a positive profit but I want to make
sure I don't make a negative profit. So,
what should I do? Yeah, over here.
Charge anywhere from C to infinity.
Exactly. And in this case, can I charge
a price of C exactly or not? Yeah. I
can. And why is that different from from
this case here? You charge C, your
profit will be zero. So, it's the same
as not Exactly. So, here we have a
closed parenthesis
and it goes like this. Notice the
difference, right? If I charge exactly
the same price as my opponent, I get
half the market.
If their price is strictly below C, then
getting half the market means I lose
money because I'm losing money on every
unit I sell.
Here getting half the market gives me a
profit of exactly zero because each unit
I sell is exactly at a price of C.
Right.
Um
now
Okay, maybe to make the cases a little
easier
let's say
I'm just going to say C is less than a
third
just to it makes so I don't have to deal
with really complicated inequalities
here. So, let's just say C is less than
a third, it's not so important.
So, now what happens if my opponent
charges
strictly more than C
um but less than or equal to 1 minus C
over 2. The 1 minus C over 2 is not
you'll see uh later why that uh
why that comes up. No, 1 plus C over 2,
sorry.
Uh so, actually I don't need
uh sorry, I don't need C less than a
third. Never mind. Ignore that. I made a
a mistake and then that caused me to
make another mistake conditional on
that. Okay. Uh so,
so now my opponent's price is strictly
greater than C. What price do I want to
charge?
Well, they're charging more than C so I
can certainly make positive profit,
right?
But what's my goal? What do I want to
try to do?
Yeah? I want to charge like as small
under P2 as possible. I want to just
undercut them.
And that kind of creates a problem here
cuz whoever much I undercut them, I
could undercut them by a little bit
less, right? Let's say I charge a dollar
less. Well, I'd rather charge a cent
less. I'd rather charge half a cent
less. So, it turns out technically
it's empty. There's not a best response
because whatever I do, I could do
strictly better because I could indeed
my goal is to undercut them by the
smallest amount and I can't undercut
them by zero because then I only get
half the market. So, I really want to be
strictly it's the classic thing. What's
the biggest number that's strictly less
than one? Well, it doesn't exist, right?
Now, as soon as I write this down, I
think you should some warning bells
should go off and you should say, well,
is this all this analysis being driven
some weird things about the real numbers
and limits not existing
um or is this really something about the
real world? And you should ask, well,
what would happen if we required prices
to be on a finite grid and say prices
have to be denominated in cents. And it
turns out that the conclusions will be
basically the same. So, whenever you you
have this sinking feeling that there's
some weird math going on, you should ask
this question and people have and it
turns out the answer is the same. So,
that's that's why we're not too
concerned. Um okay. And then the final
case
this is kind of the trickiest one where
P2 is greater than
1 plus C over 2. This is a bit
tricky. Um but what do I want to do
in this case? You might think I want to
just undercut
my opponent.
But it turns out that's not the case
here.
So, let's recall in the monopoly case
with this demand function. If I'm a
monopolist, what is the optimal price
for me to charge as a monopolist?
It turns out it's exactly 1 plus C over
2.
If I were a monopolist, that would be
the best price to charge.
So, let's say my opponent is charging a
ridiculously high price,
well, then it's as if I'm a monopolist.
And what I actually want to do is charge
exactly the monopoly price of 1 plus C
over 2.
So, notice where this undercutting
argument breaks down. You might think,
oh, I want to just undercut them but
that is assuming that they're charging a
pretty reasonable price. If they're
charging such a high price that if I
just undercut them, no one's going to
buy from me, then I just undercutting
them no longer makes sense. So, if
they're charging strictly more than the
monopoly price, then I can just charge
the monopoly price. I'm charging less
than them so I get the whole market and
in fact I get the highest possible
profit because I get exactly the
monopoly profit. So, here
you get the monopoly profit.
So, now we can work this all out. We
understand the best response of firm one
to firm two. We can compute firm two's
best response to firm one, but it turns
out if we do all the math, there's a
unique equilibrium
in which P1 star equals P2 star
equals C.
So we both charge exactly C.
And we can check.
It's easy to see that this is an
equilibrium. Showing it's unique is a
bit more work, but seeing it's an
equilibrium, if my opponent charges C,
I'm willing to charge C.
And therefore, if we each charge C, this
is an equilibrium.
Now notice a fundamental difference
between Cournot and Bertrand. With
Cournot, each time we added a firm, the
price got closer and closer to the
efficient price of C.
With Bertrand, it only takes two.
As soon as we had two firms competing,
this undercutting motive was so strong
that made it we immediately got down to
the efficient price of price equals
marginal cost.
All right, I'll end there and I'll see
everyone on Thursday.